la bande de veau
je suis pas un membre normal du
vieillissant
qu'est-ce qui se passe
alors moi aussi je fume et je bois et
regarder moi je pète le feu
[Musique]
il a laissé un mot dans son téléphone il
a écrit cigale
un groupe d'agent dormant implanté dans
la société britannique
les cigales ont été réactivées on
s'apprête à avoir d'autres victimes si
vous avez retrouvé ces traces aussi vite
elle devait pas être si bien cachée que
ça merci
franchement pas besoin que tu as été
déterré le passé
peut-être que la méfiance est un peu
trop facile vous pourriez développer il
y a autre chose
[ __ ] il y a eu une alerte on avait un
traître au sommet de la pyramide et il a
encore des comptes arriver
c'est un petit avion madame il est
bourré d'explosif
[Musique]
pour mourir aujourd'hui quelquefois la
seule façon de comprendre les raisons et
l'objectif d'un piège cette foncer
dedans
[Musique]